here's what people don't understand
about the one percent so my dad
one percent earner my mom one percent
earner they both worked at a software
company company for 25 years
sold it after 25 years and here's what
people don't understand about that one
percent
they do not care
about designer they don't care about
flexing they don't care about saying i
live a better life than you
i live a life that you you guys dream up
like
you don't even understand that behavior
is so trashy to people that actually
have wealth power and influence it is so
trashy like it is looked down upon it is
it is gross to like the top one percent
and
i'm not saying they don't make purchases
but
in a wealthy person's mind the way they
look at a designer bag a ferrari like
whatever it is
they look at that as a waste of money
because that money could be invested and
it could be going to
further generations
and to like the next generation the next
generation and
that's what people don't understand
about the one percent like my whole life
my dad told me his life's goal was to
pay for me and my kids at college or me
and my siblings tell my kids me and my
siblings college so we don't have to
work as hard as he had to
like do you know how cool that is my dad
more successful than anyone anyone you
will find on the internet preaching this
financial advice preaching like he
ran i don't know 300 person company
that
had like five locations software company
for 25 years like he was so respected at
his work like people loved him
and he
never he wore sweats to work he did not
care about that stuff
he never was one he doesn't have any
social media and he would never be one
to like even if he did he would never
post
about our house our cars our
like we don't even have designer stuff
but even if we did he would never post
about it and the biggest mistake i see
people make when they first come into
money is they start to flex they start
to
you know show off to the haters which
for one you have no idea how how long
your five seconds of success is gonna
last it could last five minutes it could
last five years
wealthy people
know that theirs will last a lifetime
because they are competent they do not
have to show it off
what does mark zuckerberg wear work now
i'm not saying they don't have nice
things they typically have nice houses
they typically have
a nice car but you will never see people
like you will never see those people
looking for validation
from the outside world and flexing
because they don't have to they're
competent
you think mark zuckerberg has to flex
you think the one percent has to flex
and that is why half the time guys
half the time these people you see on
social media that are flexing these
lives they don't
have it
oh my god they don't have it i i've seen
people in our like community come and go
like they'll act like they're rich
they'll dress like they're
they'll dress like they're rich
but wealthy people
i i can't describe it it's just a gut
feeling that i get
i can tell if people just got money by
the way they carry themselves
and looking at their spending habits i
generally can tell if they're gonna keep
it
because when you grow up with those type
of people
like you you can smell cap pretty far so
i don't know i was just having a moment
where i was like thinking of stuff
about growing up wealthy and that is
probably the biggest takeaway that would
give you guys so let me know in the
comments if you agree or you disagree
don't forget to subscribe